this is mission control to j
i can't believe it's been two years
since i saw you last
[Music]
how's bobby
i miss you both so much
i'm heading out on another secret
mission
i want to come see you but
i need to keep fighting
everything i do
is to protect you
dad
come here
keep your eyes open
the game is called get in the car as
fast as humanly possible you let him
beat you
it's okay
what's going on here road trip with my
boys
at 3am
no please stop
this operation extends to all adjacent
states
they have no idea the kind of danger
that they're in
why can't we go home it's hitting a road
trip it's a rescue mission
nothing bad's gonna happen to all i'm
around besides if this ain't a hell of
an adventure i know what it is dude
i think i'm making it up no
you're so sure
if we do this thing right
you will always be a hero to your sons
you ever heard of the three musketeers
the toughest soldiers there ever was
they could survive anything because they
stuck together now you're telling me if
we don't stand by each other
we can't get through anything
yes
i know again
[Music]
[Music]
you